so next game against Kapun from
Sweden yes I play myself
so to speak my white
opening yes okay that lets me play E5
and
D4 yes is of course normal here generally this
is a variant that
is actually a bit better for white but where black because of the
space advantage  I always get certain chances
so I get back with the espringer
because the B8 knight might have to go to
C5. On the other hand, you don't get the pieces
positioned so well to
get there, yes typical bonuses or
Volga
position I know but he
hasn't sacrificed a pawn, he still has the
A2 like that
H6 as a
preparation move should also
prevent all eventualities here, okay he
wants H straight in. Maybe I should have
used that better, a bit unpleasant
that he comes in there,
let's
see. Unfortunately, during the whole action
I ignored runner H3,
so I have to have runner H3  Play
actually
pull F5, which of course wasn't exactly what I
wanted, but he
probably doesn't try to just
pull C5 knight C4 back and bring the
next knight in there,
well, it's better to go back with the rook
so maybe I ca
n't do a nice position now, okay, I have to
take the bishop away, God, but B7 actually just hung
well.
Deck from the
side,
so the question is whether I still
have a big problem here, of course,
maybe I can still put it in there.
I would like to move knight C5.
I'll try to see if he can
he allows that,
so now I can at least
swap this one away so now I
basically still have the idea C5 and A4
A5 if I try the following rook
e to C7 and on A4 then knight
A5 that blocks the two pawn moves
okay now he does it  Yes,
I think that makes
sense, I don't have much of a
choice, and now he might want to pick
it up with rook D5,
I can't really
prevent it  the direct
attack on the
pawn very unpleasant position rook
E5 well I cover the E7 so that I have rook
C5
the position is immediately
ok again at least halfway if I
get the rooks away
so he allowed all of this
here I think he has to be on C5 now too
exchanging is problematic Rook C5 bc5
E3 with the idea of ​​getting real direct
passed pawns later h he also saw that it's
dangerous
so um I can hardly allow
him to take and then C5 sh so
I'll take the
route D4 yeah well I'll try  I
have King D6 on d4 so it's blocked at least for
a moment. What's
unpleasant is that they're on white here.
aha he closes it completely. I find it
surprising that he can now get
through
F here
so
that's actually a pretty good
blockade now  Knight to F6
and I can
commute here, it's difficult
to do anything active here, okay, I'll take the
covered passed pawn, even if that
puts the pawns on white, which I don't
want to do, but it's really difficult to
see W should progress here, I can
too  Just pick up the pawn by the way,
I just don't know if that's enough to
win after when I
go into the pawn endgame I have
two free pawns but he also has
a protected one and they
typically don't get through on their own if I play
the game now because maybe F6 I  ma
first myself
F6 so
knight D6 takes bishop takes
king takes and then king E5 I
have two connected ones but I do
n't think I can get them any
further white
resign he just gave up I
don't know
why yes I'm amazed he just
gave up
and I understand  not exactly why
knight I then have the two
passed pawns but I need the king
so that they can continue to get through and then
he starts running himself so I'll be
surprised if that's won just
switch on the computer for a moment what it thinks
it also goes into the pawn
endgame and gives  - 1.5 I have no idea how
low this one is and whether he can evaluate it correctly.
I'll go into
examination mode for a moment and try to check it out.
Check
that Remi doesn't want anything
- 1.9 but he's just oscillating
in that direction  Variant there is nothing that cannot be
done and giving up is always good when
the opponent does it